they are installed era at four pleasant
tiara noble placed our garden in
physiology or medicine it is a great
honor to introduce the Nobel laureate in
physiology or medicine dr. Andrew fire
your Royal Highnesses members of the
Nobel Committee ladies and gentlemen
perhaps some of you know of a somewhat
obscure poetic tradition that has been
handed down through many generations of
life on the American frontier if not
please prepare yourself for a top ten
list that has been composed for this
occasion ten reasons for the return of
2006 Nobel laureates to Stockholm during
the first week of December 2036 number
10 and least likely to receive an
unprecedented 31st consecutive Nobel
Prize in one field of expertise number
nine to observe one's great great great
grandchild having with the remarkable
set of equations solve the problems of
aging time travel and responsible
investment is awarded simultaneous Nobel
prizes in physics chemistry physiology
or medicine and economics number eight
to observe on a quick side trip to Oslo
as one's former Nobel attach a is
awarded the nobel peace prize for their
outstanding career with the Swedish
foreign ministry number seven to observe
one or several of one's former students
from the currently under developed world
receiving a prize for their efforts in
the newly formed and generously funded
international consortium on research
number six to observe the awarding of
the newly announced keulen area
achievement prize in honor of alfred
nobel to the room service chef from the
grand hotel
number five to finally observe the
beauty of Stockholm covered with snow
number four to Baskin swim in the 30
degree centigrade warmth of stock homes
recently developed winter beach resorts
number three to pursue the many
productive scientific collaborations
begun during the original 2006 visit to
Sweden's universities number two because
Sweden really knows how to throw a party
and number one because we and our
families have so much enjoyed the
wonderful people land and traditions of
Sweden we learned about on our first
trip to your country many thanks to all
of you
you